what's going on everybody it's Warren
and today we have even more information
about dr. strange in the multiverse of
madness and Wanda vision yesterday I
talked about a plot league for dr.
strange in the multiverse of madness and
today we have even more to add on to
this we've actually received some
confirmations about a few things that
this plot leaked States so the validity
of this plot leak has gone up and like I
mentioned yesterday this is the very
first plot leak that we've gotten for
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness it's the first one that we've
gotten since the movie has been
announced there were some before the
movie was announced before we knew it
was called Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness and they were more
fan fiction than anything but this is
the first one that we've gotten after
and there's a lot of things that are
really exciting and just really make a
lot of sense and like I said now a few
things about this plot League have been
confirmed so I'll go over the entire
plot leak but first if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU
and so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 and
I'll talk more about the rules at the
end of this video
so this leak comes from reddit and 4chan
so like with all leaks take it with a
grain of salt
so the leak starts off by saying that
this film will indeed be a horror film
now this of course Marvel has already
confirmed they have already stated that
this is going to be the MCS first horror
film but it will be pg-13 and another
thing that it says which is already
confirmed by Marvel is that it's going
to tie in directly to Wanda and vision
the league says that in the series Wanda
will go insane and she splits open the
multiverse Stephen is torn between
trying to kill her or redeem her because
he knows that she is a good person deep
down Stephen also has to find a way to
repair the shattered multiverse before
everything goes to hell
Wanda will get a brand new look in the
movie that is scary and it's going to
highlight the which part of her
character and this league says it's also
going to include her crown which is a
classic look that we've all been waiting
for
and according to this leak Monica
Rambeau Darcy Lewis and Jimmy woo will
also be a part of this movie as well
people have been speculating how Monica
gets her powers in the MCU well Monica
will get killed in Wanda vision but
Stephen enters a universe where instead
of Carol Danvers getting blasted by the
space stone maria rambo gets blasted by
the space stone maria was pregnant at
the time although she
did not know it and Monica inherits her
mother's powers and becomes photon when
she grows up now if we're dealing with
the multiverse which we know we are
because it is titled Doctor Strange and
the multiverse of madness it makes sense
that he'll go from one universe to
another universe so we'll definitely see
different variations of different
characters and it also makes sense that
Wanda going crazy makes this happen
because this is straight from the House
of M comic line but the leak also says
that we're going to be getting some new
characters which include Clea a seasoned
sorcerer from the Hong Kong sanctum that
Stephen falls in love with Jericho drum
a necromancer from the London sanctum
whose parents were evil vu duyst and of
course Wong Christine and the ancient
one are returning now this is really
interesting hearing that dr. strange is
going to fall in love with Clea
especially since Christine is still
going to be in the sequel granted the
two of them aren't really in a
relationship or anything healthy for
that matter but it definitely seemed
like they both wanted to be in Doctor
Strange and she is confirmed to be
coming in the sequel so this will be
interesting to see how it plays out the
main villain is stated to be nightmare
an interdimensional demon who feeds on
people's fears now nightmare is the
villain that people have been
speculating for this film for a super
long time especially after Marvel
announced that the multiverse of madness
is going to be a Horror Story nightmare
as a villain for the horror story just
fits and according to this leaked
nightmare is going to be eating at Wanda
influencing her terror and making her go
insane and joining nightmare is going to
be Agatha Harkness who is a disciple of
Nightmare who was proficient in
witchcraft and Shuma gorath the Lord of
chaos Shima gorath makes perfect sense
because Shima gorath appears in multiple
different dimensions in the comics and
since we are dealing with the multiverse
here Shima gorath makes perfect sense
then there's a really interesting part
about this leak it says that Wiccan is
going to be assisting dr. strange now
for those of you who do not know Wiccan
is Wanda's son it's been speculated a
while that Wiccan was going to make an
appearance in Wanda vision it's a show
about Wanda and vision being together so
it would make sense that they would have
kids and yesterday we actually got word
that the Wanda vision Disney Plus show
is casting right now and right now
they're casting two babies now again for
those of you who do not
Wanda and vision actually have two kids
in the comics Wiccan and speed and now
that we've heard they're casting two
babies for the show it's pretty much all
but confirmed that Wiccan and speed are
going to be in the show but this is very
very interesting because it really does
seem like we are following the House of
M a comic line now Wanda going crazy and
splitting open the multiverse this is
pretty much what she did in the House of
M except she created an alternate
reality but the reason she had this
mental breakdown and the reason she
created this alternate reality is
because she lost her kids and this plot
leaked only says that Wiccan is going to
be helping dr. strange could that mean
that at one point in time in the Wanda
vision series she loses speed so that's
really interesting but the most
interesting part about this leak is that
it says that Marvel zombies are going to
play a part in this movie
it says we'll see a zombie Captain
America a zombie Ironman and a zombie
Doctor Strange it also says that will
see the sorcerers battle a zombie Hulk
which is weird because the Hulk isn't
dead but of course this leek says that
these are going to come from a different
timeline again a multiverse of madness
they're going to be exploring different
timelines different universes everything
you can think of and again this movie is
going to be a horror movie and it's not
like Marvel hasn't recently done Marvel
Zombies we saw some be iron man and
spider-man far from home now of course
it wasn't real but these zombies and
multiverse of madness wouldn't really be
real either they would be from a
different universe or a different
timeline so it's not like they would
exactly be bringing these characters
back but that is what the leak says
about what we should expect to see in
Doctor Strange the multiverse of madness
so what do you think about this if this
leak is true would you like this movie
is this something that you would like to
see in the multiverse of madness be sure
to let me know in the comments down
below also don't forget to like the
video if you enjoyed it and subscribe to
my channel so you can enter my giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4
and stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU don't forget to
follow me on Twitter and Instagram as
well and as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof